we're often appalled by how sly and
dishonest many politicians are
but we shouldn't be in moves like this
we need to remember
and read the works of nicolo machiavelli
a late 15th century political advisor
and political theorist
who argued that we shouldn't think the
politicians are immoral
and simply bad for lying and dissembling
and maneuvering
a good politician in machiavelli's
remarkable view
isn't one who's friendly and honest and
kind it's someone
however occasionally dark and underhand
they might be
who knows how to defend enrich and bring
honor to
the state which is also an extremely
important goal being nice may well be a
virtue in general
but what citizens most need from their
rulers is effectiveness
which may well call upon some darker
arts
once we understand this basic
requirement we stand to be less
disappointed and clearer about what we
want from
our politicians nicolo machiavelli was
born in florence in 1469
his father was a lawyer and so
machiavelli received an extensive formal
education
and got his first job as a secretary for
the city of florence
but soon after his appointment florence
exploded politically
and expelled the medici family who'd
ruled it for 60 years
and suffered decades of political
instability and turmoil
as a consequence machiavelli experienced
a series of career reversals
over just a few decades he went from
being an important diplomat
to a semi-successful general to an enemy
of the state
tortured and then exiled when the medici
returned to power
although machiavelli was rather a failed
politician he can be remembered as a
truly great man
because of two works he wrote the prince
and the discourses
in them he attends to a central problem
of politics then as now
that it's almost impossible to be both a
good politician
and a good person in the traditional
christian sense
machiavelli proposed that the
overwhelming responsibility of a good
prince
is to defend the state from external and
internal threats
to stable governance this means he must
know how to fight
but more importantly he must know about
reputation and the management of those
around him people should neither think
he is soft and easy to disobey
nor should they find him so cruel that
he disgusts his society
he should seem unapproachably strict but
reasonable
when machiavelli turned to the question
of whether it was better for a prince
to be loved or feared he wrote that
while it would theoretically be
wonderful for a leader
to be both loved and obeyed a prince
should always err on the side of
inspiring terror
for this is ultimately what keeps people
in check
machiavelli's christian contemporaries
had suggested that princes should be
merciful
peaceful generous and tolerant they
thought that being a good politician was
in short
the same as being a good christian but
machiavelli argues differently
he asked his readers to dwell on the
incompatibility between christian ethics
and good governance
and particularly refer to the case of
gerolimo savinarola
savinarola was a dominican friar a
fervent idealistic christian
who'd briefly come to be the ruler of
florence in 1494.
he'd come to power promising to build
the city of god on earth in florence
he'd preached against the excesses and
tyranny of the medici government
and even managed for a few months to
lead florence as a peaceful democratic
and
relatively honest state however
savinarola's success could not last
because
in machiavelli's view it was based on
the weakness that always attends being
good in the christian sense it was not
long before his regime became a threat
to the corrupt pope alexander
whose henchman captured and tortured
savinarola hung him in the centre of
florence and burnt the body before the
eyes of a now vengeful citizenry
this in machiavelli's eyes is what tends
to happen to the nice guys in politics
rather than follow this unfortunate
christian example machiavelli suggested
that a leader
would do well to make judicious use of
what he called virtu
virtue machiavelli's concept of virtue
for politicians
involves wisdom strategy strength
bravery
and when necessary ruthlessness in fact
at one point machiavelli uses the
deliciously paradoxical phrase
criminal virtue to describe the
necessary ability of leaders
to be cruel in the name of the state and
yet still good
as leaders machiavelli provided some
criteria for what constitutes the right
occasion for a bit of criminal virtue
any violence must be strictly necessary
for the security of the state
it must be done swiftly often at night
council machiavelli
and it shouldn't be repeated too often
lester reputation for mindless brutality
builds up machiavelli gave the example
of his contemporary
chezry borgia whom he admired as someone
who knew how to be tough but not too
tough
though we might question the criteria
machiavelli used when chisering
conquered the city of cesina he ordered
one of his nurseries remira de orco
to bring order to the region which
romero did through swift and brutal ways
men were beheaded in front of their
wives and children property was seized
traitors were castrated chisery then
turned onto orca himself
and had him sliced in half and placed in
the public square just to remind the
townspeople who the true boss was
but then as machiavelli approvingly
noted that was enough bloodshed
chezry moved on to cut taxes imported
some cheap grain
built a theater and organized a series
of beautiful festivals
to keep people from dwelling on
unfortunate memories
the catholic church banned machiavelli's
works for 200 years
because of the force with which he had
argued that being a good christian
was incompatible with being a good
leader but
even for atheists and those of us who
are not politicians
machiavelli's insights are important he
writes that we cannot be good at or for
all things not only because of our
limited abilities and resources
but also because of conflicts within
moral codes
some of the fields we choose if not
politics then perhaps business or family
life
may require what we evasively call
difficult
decisions by which we really mean
ethical trade-offs
we may have to sacrifice neo-christian
visions of kindness
for the sake of practical effectiveness
we may have to lie
in order to keep a relationship afloat
we may have to ignore the feelings of
certain employees
to keep a business going and that in cis
machiavelli
is the price of dealing with the world
as it is and not as we feel it should be
the world has continued to love and hate
machiavelli in equal measure
for insisting on focusing our attention
on the uncomfortable tension
between two things we love and always
want to have together but perhaps can't
effectiveness and niceness
you